her face is one everyone here recognizes
that's why kahshanna burgers era avoids
public places she's been fighting for
gay and lesbian rights in Uganda for
more than 16 years but in Britain so
many times I can't count how many times
I've been bitten people have come out
openly on social media and saying if
they get hold of me I went to cut off my
head they're going to put trucks on on
my body and all this so I have to really
really always watch my back
kahshanna Becca Sarah rarely leaves her
home these days but she says there is an
upside to the threat she receives people
can no longer deny there are gays and
lesbians in Uganda I live here with my
partner and my cousin brother and his
pattern so it's a gay house it's
probably the only gay in Kampala no oh
we have so many people who are living
together secretly some pretend to be
best friends and others pretend to be
actually married so yes we have actually
you in the pink village of Uganda Uganda
is said to have half a million gays and
lesbians but the figure could well be
higher this group wants to change
people's attitudes with a magazine
called bombastic directed mainly at
techo sexuals and an annual parade
already in its fourth year they're
getting a lot of help from abroad
supporters of the movement are donating
money to the magazine but at home
they're harassed by the media the very
organizations they depend on to speak up
for them these are the people we live
with do that people were pelting stones
to us these are the people who are
pointing fingers these are people who
are sexually abusing us who are beating
us so we need them to report positive is
that we can minimize these risks in 2014
Ugandan lawmakers made same-sex
relations punishable by life sentences
judges struck down the law under
international pressure but many believe
the law still contributed to homophobia
in Uganda I'm totally against
homosexuality if a guy sleeps with you
you'll shrivel up down below but if
you're poor and gays want to sleep with
you you can earn some money it's up to
the people themselves if you don't want
to be a homo you don't have to be more
and more people in the country are
coming out crashing Ibaka Zahra says
even if they still face harsh prison
sentences
I'm really really hopeful for their
movement in Uganda because even when
others go at as commendable and but so
there is hope there is no doubt there is
hope and the movement is strong the
movement exists and the challenges are
there but we also register some
successes that keep us going
naviga sarah is an ambassador for a new
self-confident gay rights movement in
Uganda it's a struggle that's nowhere
near finished